so asking for help is basically the
worst right I don't I don't
I've actually never seen it on one of
those top ten lists of things people
fear like public speaking and death but
I'm pretty sure it actually belongs
there even though in many ways it's
foolish for us to be afraid to admit
that we need help whether it's from a
loved one or a friend or from a
co-worker or even from a stranger
somehow it always feels just a little
bit uncomfortable and embarrassing to
actually ask for help which is of course
why most of us try to avoid asking for
help whenever humanly possible
my father was one of those legions of
fathers who I swear would rather drive
through an alligator-infested swamp then
actually ask someone for help getting
back to the road
when I was a kid we took a family
vacation we drove from our home in South
Jersey to Colonial Williamsburg and I
remember we got really badly lost and my
mother and I pleaded with him to please
just pull over and ask someone for
directions back to the highway and he
absolutely refused and in fact assured
us that we were not lost
he had just always wanted to know what
was over here so if we're going to ask
for help and we have to we all do
practically every day the only way we're
gonna even begin to get comfortable with
it is to get good at it to actually
increase the chances that when you ask
for help from someone they're actually
gonna say yes and not only that but
they're gonna find it actually
satisfying and rewarding to help you
because that way they'll be motivated to
continue to help you into the future so
research that I and some of my
colleagues have done has shed a lot of
light on why it is that sometimes people
say yes to our request for help and why
sometimes they say no let me just start
by saying right now if you need help you
are going to have to ask
for it out loud okay we all to some
extent suffer from something that
psychologists call the illusion of
transparency basically the mistaken
belief that our thoughts and our
feelings and our needs are really
obvious to other people this is not true
but we believe it and so we just mostly
stand around waiting for someone to
notice our needs and then spontaneously
offer to help us with it this is a
really really bad assumption in fact not
only is it very difficult to tell what
your needs are but even the people close
to you often struggle to understand how
they can support you my partner has
actually had to adopt the habit of
asking me multiple times a day are you
okay do you need anything because I am
so so bad at signaling when I need
someone's help now he is more patient
than I deserve and much more proactive
much more about helping than any of us
have any right to expect other people to
be so if you need help you're going to
have to ask for it and by the way even
when someone can tell that you need help
how do they know that you want it did
you ever try to give unsolicited help to
someone who it turns out did not
actually want your help in the first
place they get nasty real quick don't
they the other day true story
um my teenage daughter was getting
dressed for school and I decided to give
her some unsolicited help about that um
I happen to think she looks amazing in
brighter colors she tends to prefer sort
of darker more neutral tones and so I
said very helpfully that I thought maybe
she could go back upstairs and try to
find something a little less somber so
if looks could kill I would not be
standing here right now we really can't
blame other people for not just
spontaneously offering to help us when
we don't actually know that that's what
is wanted in fact actually research
shows that 90% of the help that
co-workers give one another in the
workplace is in response to explicit
requests for help so you're gonna have
to say the words I need your help right
there's no getting around it now to be
good at it
right to make sure that people actually
do help you when you ask for it there
are a few other things that are very
helpful to keep in mind first thing when
you ask for help
be very very specific about the help you
want and why they sort of indirect
requests for help actually aren't very
helpful to the helper right we don't
actually know what it is you want from
us and and just as important we don't
know whether or not we can be successful
in giving you the help nobody wants to
give bad help like me you probably get
some of these requests from perfectly
Pleasant strangers on LinkedIn who want
to do things like get together over
coffee and connect or pick your brain I
ignore these requests literally every
time and it's not that I'm not a nice
person it's just that when I don't know
what it is you want from me like the
kind of help you're hoping that I can
provide I'm not interested nobody is I'd
have been much more interested if they
had just come out and said whatever it
was who they were hoping to get from me
because I'm pretty sure they had
something specific in mind so go ahead
and say I'm hoping to discuss
opportunities to work in your company or
I'd like to propose a joint research
project in an area I know you're
interested in or I'd like your advice on
getting into Medical School technically
I can't help you with that last one
because I'm not that kind of doctor but
I could point you in the direction of
someone who could okay so second tip
this is really important please avoid
disclaimers apologies and bribes really
really important so do any of these
sound familiar I'm so so sorry that I
have to ask you for this i I really hate
bothering you with this if I had any way
of doing this without your help I would
sometimes it feels like people are so
eager to prove that they're not weak and
greedy when they ask you for help
they're completely missing out on how
uncomfortable they're making you feel
and by the way how am I supposed to find
it satisfied
to help you if you really hated having
to ask me for help okay and while it's
perfectly perfectly acceptable to pay
strangers to do things for you you need
to be very very careful when it comes to
incentivizing your friends and
co-workers when you have a relationship
with someone helping one another is
actually a natural part of that
relationship it's how we show one
another that we care if you introduce
incentives or payments into that what
can happen is it starts to feel like it
isn't a relationship it's a transaction
and that actually is experienced as
distancing which ironically makes people
less likely to help you so a spontaneous
gift after someone gives you some help
to show your appreciation and gratitude
perfectly fine an offer to pay your best
friend to help you move into your new
apartment is not okay third rule and I
really mean this one please do not ask
for help over email or text really
seriously please don't email and text
are impersonal and I really sometimes
there's no alternative but mostly what
happens is we like to ask for help over
email and text because it feels less
awkward for us to do so you know what
else feels less awkward over email and
text telling you no and it turns out
there's research to support this in
person requests for help are 30 times
more likely to get a yes than a request
made by email so when something is
really important you really need
someone's help make FaceTime to make the
request or use your phone as a phone
to ask for the help that you need okay
last one and this is actually a really
really important one and probably the
one that is most overlooked when it
comes to asking for help when you ask
someone for their help and they say yes
follow up with them afterward there's a
common misconception that what's
rewarding about helping is the act of
helping itself this is not true
what is rewarding about helping is
knowing that your help land it that it
had impact that you were effective if I
have no idea how my help affected you
how am I supposed to feel about it this
happened I was a university professor
for many years I wrote lots and lots of
letters of recommendation for people to
get jobs or to go into graduate school
and probably about 95 percent of them I
have no idea what happened now how do I
feel about sort of the time and effort I
took to do that when I really have no
idea if I helped you if it actually
helped you get the thing that you wanted
in fact this idea of feeling effective
as part of why certain kinds of donor
appeals are so so persuasive because
they allow you to really vividly imagine
the effect that your help is gonna have
so take something like DonorsChoose you
go online you can choose the individual
teacher by name whose classroom that
you're going to be able to help by
literally buying the specific items
they've requested like microscopes or
laptops or flexible seating an appeal
like that makes it so easy for me to
imagine the good that my money will do
that I actually get an immediate sense
of effectiveness the minute I commit to
giving but you know what else they do
they follow up so donors actually get
letters from the kids in the classroom
they get pictures they get to know that
they made a difference and this is
something we need to all be doing in our
everyday lives especially if we want
people to continue to give us help over
the long term take time to tell your
colleague that the help that they gave
you really helped you land that big sale
or helped you get that interview that
you were really hoping to get take time
to tell your partner that the support
they gave you really made it possible
for you to get through a tough time
take time to tell your cat sitter that
you're super happy that for some reason
this time the cats didn't break anything
while you were away and so they must
have done a really good job but the
bottom line is I know believe me I know
that it is not easy to ask for help we
are all a little bit afraid to do it it
makes us feel vulnerable but the reality
of modern work and modern life is that
nobody does it alone nobody succeeds in
a vacuum more than ever we actually do
have to rely on other people on their
support and collaboration in order to be
successful so when you need help ask for
it out loud and when you do do it in a
way that increases your chances that
you'll get a yes and makes the other
person feel awesome for having helped
you because you both deserve it thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]